the walking dead is such a phenom and
when i was like looking over your career
a lot of times you're the guy who comes
into a pre-existing cast a show that's
already on the air
it's a tougher position to enter into a
successful show am i correct
yeah well because if then the ratings
drop or the story
doesn't keep uh the audience riveted as
it has for the previous seven years you
know who's going to take the blame is
he's [ __ ] me you believe you believe
uh that so was there a fear when you
took the negan roll that you were gonna
[ __ ] up the show
well i think for a couple reasons one is
just because that role
in itself is is a is a big ballsy role
uh it sure is you know i think that's a
tough [ __ ] role it's a tough
challenge and he talks
so [ __ ] much yeah i mean it's it's
non-stop before i get a script for an
episode
negan talks 99 of it and then rick
grunts
yeah right i was gonna say there isn't a
dialogue
no it's a monologue monologue as an
actor do you get resentful of that or do
you say to yourself hey this is good for
me i like to get busy
like help me out here yeah i'm like let
somebody else talk yeah
i think it's fascinating i don't know
how many people understand how you got
that role you were on a show called the
good wife yeah it was very successful on
cbs
and while you're on that show i guess
the people contacted you and said hey we
want you to play a role on the walking
dead but we can't tell you what it is
exactly right yeah and and like what is
that all about because they wanted to
keep the negan character so top secret
yeah i mean
and now that i've been with the show for
a year everything is shrouded in secrecy
like we don't we don't even get scripts
until the last minute which for me is
horrible because i usually have so much
talking
now describe that because when you film
the first episode yeah
you have they give you the script 48
hours in advance yes
and you are the entire episode was the
last uh last episode of season six yeah
it was last 15 minutes of it and it was
just
one big big monologue you can memorize
that in in uh
in two days well luckily what happened i
was here in new york doing the good wife
and we got the call about the show and
they wouldn't tell me who it was
and by the way isn't that a great moment
in your career when you don't have to
audition and like they just call you and
say thank [ __ ] god
right oh god because i hate auditioning
i i i mean i always i was never very
good at it and
and thankfully ever since i did grey's
anatomy
right you know 10 years ago or whatever
it was now i haven't had to audition for
anything
i think the last audition i had was for
watchmen isn't that nice
that's the greatest thing in the world
they think of you as negan
like it wasn't like they sat right and
came up with 20 other guys yeah that i
found that to be
a little crazy actually i guess the
comedian in washington was the closest
thing i'd ever done to that character
but
but yeah i think that was taking a
chance on their part especially
considering i think what you most people
would see me in at that time
was either good wife or or or uh grey's
anatomy so it's a big jump
how do they know you can handle it and
like how do you even know you can handle
doing it they don't show you a script
right
yeah did they just and they wouldn't
discuss the character negan they just
said we want you for something
here's they knew they called and said
it's going to be a villain
and because i'm a fan of the show i know
kind of exactly where we are
in the story and so i was like oh it's
[ __ ] negan right you know that was
i knew immediately that familiar with
the comic book and all well
you know when the this character was
first introduced i was at a comic-con
and someone a fan came up to me and said
oh they just introduced his character in
walking dead and you should be this guy
and that was five years ago fans said
that to you yeah but
to think that the creators of the show
said hey this guy would be perfect yeah
because your role in good wife is so
opposite that
very much the opposite you know i've
done enough stuff i guess that
if you look for it you can find me
playing a bad guy in various things
here's the thing though i heard you i i
think you said this and it was actually
very profound for me it changed
my thinking on something did you say
maybe i have this wrong that
negan when you were preparing the the
the character
that negan thinks of himself as a good
guy in other words he was attacked by
this crew of people
they killed his people he doesn't see
himself as a bad man
i thought that was pretty interesting
you know what it's interesting that you
should say that because
i you know i often hear actors say they
don't think of their characters as
villains yeah that they've got to find
something they like about them something
good about them yeah i was like what do
you find about negan yeah that resonated
for me if i think if you put yourself in
this
apocalyptic zombified world um
i think anybody that survived this long
has probably done some bad things if you
look at
rick and their survivors they've done
some horrible right
they killed 30 of my men while they
slept that's right you know
and so so far i've tapped a couple dudes
in the head with a baseball bat and all
of a sudden
when you mention that it's kind of like
hey you don't come to think of it you
should [ __ ] kill a few more of them